E aí
[Música]
se
você já pararam para pensar que os
debates em torno das demais unidades
muitas vezes carecem de um recorte
racial
ET por conta disso a gente acaba por
naturalizar certas falas que além de
racistas elas também ou Borão com a
lógica da masculinidade hegemônica
hoje eu vim falar com vocês sobre isso a
partir do viés das maternidades amarelas
e quem nunca ouviu por exemplo a piada
de que Japonês tem pinto pequeno
Me diz um tempo os debates sobre as
artes amarelos no Brasil tem crescido
muito sobretudo nas redes sociais e
muito tem se falado por exemplo sobre
os trotes de musculação né ou seja o
estereótipo de que pessoas amarelas
designadas homens ao nascer são
desprovidos de masculinidade
e tendo como ponto de referência
obviamente mas unidade de Mônica que
branca e ocidental
o que mais me interessa muito mais aqui
trabalhar com como que esse esse
protótipo foi construído o que que clica
nele e como que a gente lida com isso aí
velho só apontar que esse estereótipo
tenho inveja Rafa
bom então vamos lá vamos começar
contextualizando
é isso espera aó tipo é sustentado por
um Imaginário ambientalista ele
ele se constrói sobretudo a partir de
hoje política gente migratórias que os
Estados Unidos
impuseram em relação à população
asiática
a essas políticas junto com
práticas econômicas discriminatórios
ajudaram a desenvolver um processo de
racionalização que é mais pulou esses
corpos
e Vale lembrar
também a questão essa da minha porque
homens asiáticos eles só vão conquistar
o status de cidadão estadunidenses nos
anos 1940 só e o status de cidadania é
sustentada pela ideia do Patriarca chefe
de família e do exercício da Maternidade
Então é só quando esses homens é
conquistam é esses tacos que eles de
certa forma são formalmente
designado os homens pelo estrago
estadunidense
E além disso o fato de que muitos homens
amarelos não conseguiram trazer suas
esposas para os Estados Unidos
é somado as leis anti-miscigenação
e também fez com que eles não consegui
sem construir uma família patriarcal e
dessa forma eles foram excluídos de uma
lógica ter normativa
é a questão da
falta de oportunidade de empregos
sustentáveis por um
placas discriminatórias também fez com
que eles fossem colocados empregos
considerados para mulher
o e
posteriormente a construção do mito da
minoria modelo que é esse mito em que as
artes são colocadas como estudiosos
trabalhadores inteligentes esforçados
politicamente inofensivos e sobretudo
não lembro
me ajudou também a corroborar com o que
a gente pode chamar de a construção de
um gênero racializado é importante que a
gente a gente entenda a dinâmica do não
negro porque a atualização amarela ela
dialoga diretamente com a atualização
Negra
e se por um lado asiáticos amarelos se
gêneros são é mais colados E com isso
tem toda aquela dinâmica né daquela
piada que eu falei inicialmente homens
negros se gêneros vão ser
hiperssexualizado zíper masculinizadas
de modo que carrega todos imaginavam
fala de dentado que vai colocar esse
corpo até mesmo como entendido entendido
como perigoso né enquanto o homem ganhou
com esse gênero
estamos um ponto de equilíbrio nesse
sentido ele vai transformar um corpo
neutro
o ou seja ele não vai ser nem a mais
colado e nem vai estar por lá um limite
de masculinidade é a ponto de ser
considerado ameaçador
Oi e a interessante a gente pensar nessa
dinâmica né do tamanho do pênis enquanto
um termômetro de maternidade porque
quanto menor seu pênis nos homens você é
quanto maior seu pênis mais homem você é
e nesse sentido se você vai muito além
do aceitável né da masculinidade
aceitável vocês estão nesse corpo
ameaçador perigoso
Oi e essa essa dinâmica também vai
dialogar muito com a questão da
transfobia se a gente for levar em conta
é que você conta mais logo seu pênis
menos amigos ideia se você for um homem
sem pênis sequer homem você vai ser
entendido como
é mas agora que a gente já entendeu Como
que essa dinâmica estudam como que esses
eróticos são construídos eu acho que
vale a pena a gente também entender de
que forma esses debates responsável
faltado eu tenho percebido o movimento
muito grande é vindo de homem esse
gênero já transexuais amarelos é de
culpabilizar mulheres pela musculação
como a sua se fosse as principais
responsáveis por isso a gente precisa
ter uma visão Geral das dessas
problemáticas e não individualizar essas
questões o projetar inseguranças e
também frustrações em cima de mulheres
o outro ponto é que eu acho interessante
é de pensar é como que essas questões se
complexificam quando a gente vai pensar
por exemplo recorte gay porque a
masculinidade já Mônica tá presente
ainda na nessa comunidade e ela ainda
dita em forma dinâmica de desejo e de
desejabilidade
no sentido de aqui nesse contexto o
lugar da rejeição e da fertilização vai
ficar muito em evidência a
Ah e por fim eu não posso deixar de
mencionar
o fato de que muitos homens fizemos
amarelos vão tentar reter a um lugar de
homem a partir de uma
masculinidade extremamente agressiva
extremamente misógina estão mente
violenta
é mas agora que
agora no final eu acho tem interessante
eu parti um pouco também na minha
experiência individual na minha relação
com a temática porque por muito tempo
não sabia se a si a minha questão com a
masculinidade ela tinha a ver com a
branquitude ou como a sua generalidade
é mais em 2019 no Cine arte UFF Niterói
eu assisti ao filme [ __ ] para vestidinho
com ainda quebrada e eu comecei a
refletir a forma como eu me colocava no
mundo EA forma como as pessoas Milhão
o e em seguida conversei com duas amigas
muito queridas de Moreira e E o que
hayas e eu lembro com muitos detalhes da
fala de IP para mim no WhatsApp naquele
dia
e ela disse que esse gênero idade é
Colonial a cidade é violenta e a gente a
sofrer violências cotidianas das
idealidade
constantemente mas a gente poderia
evitar de se violentar a partir do
momento em que a gente que a gente deixa
de tentar se enquadrar no espaço que não
nos cabe
o Yuki teve uma fala similar
Mas a partir de uma experiência coletiva
em que encontra uma pessoa amarela e eu
lembro que quando io que falou meu nome
nessa conversa foi Como assim meu nome
ganhasse também uma nova semântica
EA partir desse momento eu percebi que o
lugar que a gente entende acontecido se
janeyla de hoje né que implica tudo isso
que a gente falou até agora é um lugar
aberto vídeo Oi e a gente precisa negar
esse lugar
E eu então vou quero deixar para
finalizar algumas perguntas muito
sinceras
para gente tentar tencionar um pouco
desse debate
e vale a pena negociar com a branquitude
e com a sua generalidade
e nos interessa subverter estereótipos
sustentando ainda assim uma lógica
binária
o ou nos interessa muito mais construir
um mundo em que a gente passa a ser o
que a gente quiser ser é é com essas
perguntas que eu me despeço Muito
obrigado
E aí
[Aplausos]
G1
E aí
[Música]